[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend herzlich
willkommen zur zdf heute live sie sind
keine wundermittel sie sind keine game
changer aber sie könnten helfen leben zu
retten
im kampf gegen die korona pandemie
sollen in deutschland jetzt zwei
amerikanische medikamente eingesetzt
werden beide enthalten antikörper gegen
das corona virus und sie könnten helfen
bei bestimmten risikogruppen einen
schweren krankheitsverlauf zu vermeiden
200.000 dosen hat das
bundesgesundheitsministerium bestellt
bei den us-herstellern eli lilly und
regeneron für insgesamt 400 millionen
euro eingesetzt werden sie aber zunächst
nur in speziellen kliniken denn es gibt
noch keine offizielle zulassung sondern
nur eine sogenannte not erlaubnis was
bedeuten diese medikamente im kampf
gegen cupid 19
wie wirken sie und welche risiken und
nebenwirkungen gibt es das wollen wir
besprechen in der kommenden halben
stunde zusammen mit professor doktor
stephan dübel biotechnologe an der
technischen universität braunschweig der
seit einem jahr selbst an einem ganz
ähnlichen antikörper medikament forscht
und wie immer ihr kennt das schon könnt
auch ihr eure fragen an ihn loswerden
unter diese e mail adresse ist ja
erstmal bin ich aber dran und das nutze
ich aus einen schönen guten abend
professor dübel nach braunschweig
genommen vorrichtung wir bewerten sie
denn diese neue behandlungsmöglichkeit
wie sehr kann sie helfen die
intensivstationen hier in deutschland
frei zu halten
na ja wir haben schon in gewisser weise
einen durchbruch mit diesem medikament
erreicht das ist das erste spezifisch
gegen den virus wirken der medikament
also das erste medikament was von anfang
an gegen diesen virus entwickelt wurde
und ihn tatsächlich auch neutralisieren
kann und damit ist es natürlich schon
eine qualitätsstufe über allem was man
bisher probiert hat mehr an
symptomatischen behandlung und auch an
umwidmungen von medikamenten die er
nicht so erfolgreich waren das heißt es
ist schon ein ganz wichtiger
zusätzlicher
weil in unserem köcher gegen diese
pandemie manch einwohner ist dass das
medikament erst jetzt hier eingesetzt
wird schließlich gab es schon im oktober
damals als us präsident donald trump
erkrankte an cupid 19
die information dass er mit genau einem
dieser medikamente die jetzt hier auch
zum einsatz kommen sollen behandelt
wurde und es gibt auch schon einen
notfall zulassung länger in den usa
was sagen sie zu dem zeitpunkt an dem
sich die bundesregierung nun entschieden
hat dieses medikament zu bestellen
beziehungsweise diese medikamente es
sind ja zwei also als jemand der selber
im bereich antikörper sehr aktiv ist
freut mich dass das ist so schnell wie
es jetzt gegangen ist aufgegangen ist
aber eigentlich hätte es noch schneller
gehen können
das sage ich ihnen jetzt aber als
experte der das gebiet sehr eng verfolgt
hat wir haben wir auch durchaus
entwicklungen in deutschland zahlreiche
und es ist insofern insgesamt zu
begrüßen dass die bundesregierung zu
diesem zeitpunkt eine weitere option für
die patienten geschaffen hat denen eine
impfung halt nicht hilft und das ist
dass der wichtige unterschied ja auch zu
der impfstrategie es ist ja nicht ein
weiterer impfstoff sondern es sind
mehrere zwei verschiedene momentan
hoffentlich kommen noch mehr dazu zwei
verschiedene antikörper mit einem
medikamente die eben auch schon
infizierten helfen können
wir werden uns gleich auch noch intensiv
darüber unterhalten dann über das was
sie eben gesagt haben nämlich dass es
noch etwas schneller hätte gehen können
in der tat zunächst wollen wir uns aber
erstmal anschauen wie diese medikamente
überhaupt wirken und für welche
patienten sie geeignet sind
er ist wohl der berühmteste patienten
mit sogenannten monoklonalen antikörpern
behandelt wurde nach seiner corona
infektion im vergangenen oktober lockte
donald trump die therapie in den
allerhöchsten tönen
in den usa sind die beiden medikamente
der hersteller general und eli lilly
schon offiziell zugelassen
in deutschland noch nicht das
paul-ehrlich-institut erlaubt die
anwendung dennoch nach individueller
nutzen risikobewertung so heißt es und
so wirkt die antikörpertherapie sie
greift an am sogenannten protein an der
oberfläche des co
ein virus bekommt der mensch antikörper
gespritzt verbinden diese sich mit dem
protein und das virus ist blockiert
es kann dann nicht mehr ein menschliche
zellen andocken und sich nicht mehr
vermehren
allerdings werden nicht alle erkrankten
von den neuen medikamenten profitieren
die sind auch nicht für den einsatz um
das nochmal hier klar zu sagen nicht für
den einsatz von allen kroner patienten
sondern von hochrisikopatienten oder für
hochrisiko patienten zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt der erkrankung einen sehr
frühen zeitpunkt der erkrankung im laufe
der woche werden die ersten medikamente
in ausgewählten kliniken ankommen
die kosten pro dosis 2000 euro ein
stolzer preis aber das ist nicht der
grund zumindest nicht der hauptgrund
warum das medikament erstmal nur an
einigen patienten zum einsatz kommen
soll professor dübel denn ich glaube
nicht jeder patient ist geeignet oder
könnte man theoretisch alle patienten
damit behandeln
na ja im prinzip ist die antikörper
therapie in der medizin seit 120 jahren
bekannt das wirkprinzip ist identisch zu
den blättern muss sehr um was sie
bekommen wenn sie sich an der
gartenschere geschnitten haben bei der
gartenarbeit
das ist also schon sehr lange bekannt
und was man hier natürlich in bezug auf
die patienten die man hier behandelt
sagen muss ist dass die entscheidung das
hoch risikopatienten zu geben
hochgradig zu begrüßen ist denn die sind
ja oft gerade aufgrund ihrer
vorerkrankungen die das hochrisiko
begründen durch einen impfstoff nicht so
gut zu schützen
und hier sozusagen eine weitere ebene
eine weitere behandlungsmöglichkeit eine
weitere schutzpflichten zu ziehen ist
sicherlich eine sehr gute sache
man kann allerdings antikörper auch
prophylaktisch einsatz man kann also
antikörper geben zum schutz
ich selber habe vor vielen jahren einen
schutz gegen 1 1 annika präparat gegen
einen anderen virus genommen einfach
weil ich in einer landschaft gefahren
bin wo dass eine solche erkrankung gab
man kann sich also auch mit solchen
antikörpern prophylaktisch schützen das
wäre zum beispiel für medizin person
einsetzbar oder auch für alle arten von
risikogruppen denn generell sind diese
antikörper parat recht gut verträglich
mit entsprechenden ausnahmen die man
natürlich sehr genau beobachten muss bei
denen wir auch einige kennt schon bei
den präparaten die in der us zulassung
in der murger probe zulassungen ja schon
entsprechend gewürdigt wurden und des
anwendungsprofil ist also recht
vielfältig was man auch noch verstehen
muss bei diesen hohen preis ist dass man
ja hier nicht die gesamte bevölkerung
praktisch damit behandeln muss sondern
nur die infizierten und das ist ja ein
hundertstel nur und die schwer
infizierten mit dem risiko reicht ein
tausendstel
und dann wird das ganze preislich auch
schon wieder erträglicher auch wenn
dieser preis am anfang sehr hoch ist und
vielleicht ist noch in zukunft auch
andere möglichkeiten gibt aber es ist
auf jeden fall zu begrüßen dass wir
jetzt für diese riesige patienten die
auf die impfung nicht ansprechen auch
eine behandlungsmöglichkeit haben da
kommen jetzt schon die ersten anfragen
von unseren usern nämlich wie viele
dosen man braucht fragt mm auf youtube
und patrick fragt sie gezielt auf sie
die menge für ausreichend halten die
jetzt bestellt wurden man braucht bei
einem antikörper im prinzip eine dosis
und ist sofort geschützt das ist also
auch anders als bei einer impfung hier
gibt es bestimmt auch menschen die man
die zum beispiel mit hochrisiko
patienten zu tun haben mit sinnlich das
personal was man sofort schützen könnte
wenn eben die noch kein zugriff auf die
impfung gehabt haben das ist sicherlich
eine möglichkeit die ist im moment noch
nicht angegeben in dem verwendung ziel
der veröffentlichung des modus
ministeriums aber es wäre vorstellbar
mit antikörpern apparaten das zu tun ob
das mit diesen zwei speziellen geht muss
man natürlich im einzelfall genau
untersuchen was war die zweite frage ob
sie die menge für ausreichend halten und
wie viele dosen man braucht das waren
die beiden fragen ja die menge ist
natürlich nicht viel wie auch bei den
impfstoffen weil die erste völlig neu
hergestellt wird
spezifisch gegen einen neuen virus dem
mann vor einem ja erst kennengelernt
hatte noch nie in der geschichte der
menschheit hat man so schnell ein
spezifisches gegenmittel entwickeln
können
das ist also ein sich schon weltrekord
bisher und die produktion bis die
sozusagen gesteigert wird das dauert
natürlich etwas aber da wir ja im
gegensatz zu der impfung hier sehr viel
weniger patienten behandeln müssen eben
nur die wirklich hochrisiko fälle die
auch schon
es geht ja an die uni kliniken das
medikament da bekannt sind wird man mit
diesen mengen schon sehr viel gutes tun
können
hier kommt glaube ich alle sehr
relevante frage rein von johannes walter
der schreibt dass seine eltern risiko zu
risikogruppen höhe gehören das impfen
läuft sehr schleppend an ob diese
therapie bei die wir jetzt gerade reden
das impfen denn ersetzen kann
wahrscheinlich nicht oder na ja dass man
muss immer sehen was bedeutet ersetzen
es ist möglich bei diesem virus haben
viele experten aus der biologie kollegen
von mir auch bestätigt dass dieser virus
in veränderter form in ein zwei jahren
wieder kommt und dann müssen wir neue
mission
das heißt auch eine impfung ist nicht
ein einmaliger vorgang wahrscheinlich
bei coronaviren von dem was wir jetzt
wissen und entsprechend kann man kann
man mit einem antikörper einen menschen
für einige monate eins bis drei monate
sagt man schützen
und dann müsste man das neu geben in der
zeit könnte der mensch zum beispiel auch
geimpft werden und wir kaufen also zeit
mit einem gegenmittel aber wir kaufen
auch eine therapie aktion für die ganzen
menschen die auf die impfung eben nicht
reagieren weil sie zum beispiel mit
einem um nun unterdrückende medikament
behandelt werden und deswegen keine
antwort selber entwickeln können die
können keine selber keinen eigenen
antikörper machen und deswegen können
wir ihnen die antikörper von außen geben
und ihnen damit trotzdem ein schutz
gegen den virus geben natürlich ist das
alles wissenschaftlich klinik in seiner
langzeitwirkung gar nicht erforscht bar
gewesen bisher weil wir das medikament
wurde im november zugelassen und sein
dem haben wir diese erfahrungen und wir
müssen einfach abwarten was in der
klinischen praxis sich dann ergibt mit
diesem medikament wie dort die
erfolgsraten aussehen und da werden wir
viel dazulernen und wir hoffen ja auch
das eben über diese zwei antikörper
hinaus auch noch weitere antikörper
medikamente dazu kommen die uns noch
mehr möglichkeiten geben
darüber werden auch gleich noch mal
reden hier kommen noch viele fragen
unter anderem zum preis hier wird
natürlich gefragt wie kommt diese dieser
doch hohe preis 2.000 euro pro impfdosis
nicht impfdosis pro medikamentendosis
zustande
können sie uns das erklären ja das ist
sehr einfach es ist ganz einfach eine
funktion der menge die man braucht ein
impfstoff bringt den körper dazu selber
antikörper zu produzieren ich gebe also
den bauplan und der mensch ist die
antikörper verbringen bei einem
therapeutischen gesetzten antikörper wie
den jetzt beschafften muss ich außerhalb
des körpers biotechnologisch eine
antikörper fabrik haben diese antikörper
produziert und ich brauche
dementsprechend eine sehr viel größere
menge dieses wirkstoffes beide
wirkstoffe sowohl die impfstoffe wie
auch die antikörper sind ja biologische
wirkstoffe körper bei den antikörpern
sind körpereigene moleküle und die in
der medikamenten qualität herzustellen
die eben eine risikolose verabreichung
erlaubt das ist dementsprechend einfach
teurer weil wir von diesem medikament in
reinen mengen mehr brauchen die sind
nicht zugelassen worden die medikamente
man muss es immer wieder sagen sondern
es ist eine note erlaubnis und deswegen
kommt hier natürlich auch die frage auf
wie sicher sind denn diese medikamente
was können sie da als einschätzung sagen
also zum ersten hat das
paul-ehrlich-institut drauf geschaut und
ich sage es immer wieder in den
interviews wo der stempel von denen
drauf ist
das würde ich mir bedenkenlos selber in
den arm spritzen
es ist einfach eine extrem kompetent und
extrem umfangreiche analyse auch die
dort vorgenommen wird und wir müssen
auch dabei bedenken dass ja das ganze
auch schon von der amerikanischen und
dem amerikanischen gegenpart ausführlich
geprüft wurde bis hin zu einer note
zulassung und diese note zulassung in
amerika bedeutet die fdp also die
amerikanische gesundheitsbehörde die
diese dinge zulässt hat bereits positiv
festgestellt durch ausführliche
klinische prüfungen dass dieses werk
prinzip was im moment dieses werk profil
für das die antikörper momentan
verwendet werden sicher ist denn die
allererster klinische prüfungen die
gemacht wird die geht auf die
verträglichkeit da wird geguckt wie
vertragen die menschen das gibt es
irgendwelche nebenwirkungen und wenn es
nebenwirkungen gibt dann schaut man sich
gar nicht mehr an ob das werk dann
schlägt das medikament gleich raus aus
der pipeline
also hier wird wirklich geschaut ist das
sicher und dieser prüfung sind in den
usa ausführlich gemacht worden und sogar
folge studien mit mehr patienten und
auch dort gab es nur in einigen
speziellen fällen die aber auch mit der
biologie der erkrankung zu tun haben wie
wir vermuten gab es nebenwirkungen und
die sind auch bei dem anwendungsprofil
was veröffentlicht wurde ausgeschlossen
trotzdem ist natürlich die datenlage
nicht so wie man sie sich optimalerweise
wünschen würde wenn man ein medikament
an nun wirklich einsetzt in den kliniken
und so hat sich eine diskussion
entwickelt wir hören mal rein wie sich
verschiedene fachleute dazu geäußert
haben
die therapie mit monoklonalen
antikörpern bei wissenschaftlern gibt es
dazu verschiedene meinungen
grundsätzlich halte ich es für sinnvoll
dass man solche neuen medikamente auch
wenn sie es noch in einem frühen stadium
sind geschafft einfach weil man dadurch
eine neue handlungsoptionen schafft
anderen sind die daten noch zu dünn ist
die wirksamkeit nicht stark genug belegt
wir hoffen uns von diesen antikörpern
dass sie den übergang von der saat koch
zwei infektionen eine schwere kurs 19
erkrankung mildern aber dafür gibt es
keine sehr gute evidenz momentan aus den
durchgeführten studien
die infektiologie in maryland addo sagt
die medikamente könnten ein weiterer
baustein in der bekämpfung der pandemie
seien
wir erwarten aber keine ultimativen
heilsbringer ich möchte noch mal
nachfragen professor dübel bei den
impfstoffen jetzt zum beispiel bei
beyond eck und versah war ganz klar die
eu sei entscheidend für alle
mitgliedsstaaten die ema die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde hat das ganze
geprüft das paul-ehrlich-institut hier
in deutschland hat dann noch endgültig
grünes licht gegeben warum geht das hier
bei diesen medikamenten offensichtlich
anders und ist dieser weg nicht nötig
können sie uns das erklären
ja das kann man vielleicht daraus
erklären dass wir gesagt menschliche
antikörper körpereigene moleküle sind
und deswegen sich doch deutlich
unterscheiden die in ihrem üblichen
nebenwirkungsprofil also deutlich
gutmütiger verhalten als körpereigene
stoffe als ein handelsüblicher oder wald
oder wiesen chemie chemisch hergestellte
wirkstoff der in irgendwelchen organen
toxizitäten haben kann die man noch
nicht kennt beim antikörper wissen wir
genau wo der ist da ist in der blutbahn
weil wieder von ihnen sie und ich haben
in diesem moment mehrere gramm
antikörper in unserem blut die
zirkulierenden aufpassen als polizisten
der blutbahn sozusagen das heißt wir
haben sehr lange erfahrung mit dieser
diesem prinzip diese anwendung von
neutralisierenden antikörpern
ein beispiel diphtherie serien aus
verden haben hunderttausende von kindern
das leben gerettet bevor es den
impfstoff gehabt also es ist hier
durchaus eine lange medizinische praxis
die auch sehr viel erfahrungen damit
begründet kleine kommentar zu den
heilsbringern ich glaube es ist wichtig
dass wir nicht auf ein pferd setzen wir
können uns nicht auf einen heilsbringer
verlassen wir können nicht sagen die
impfung bett das problem für ewig lösen
sondern wir müssen bei einem so derart
noch in der forschung nicht
hundertprozentig verstandenen virus alle
optionen nutzen um das schnellstmöglich
in den griff zu bekommen und da sind die
antikörper ein bewährtes seit 120 jahren
bewährtes instrument was
ja auch geschafft hat in diesem fall das
erste spezifische heilmittel gegen caen
mit 19 zu erbringen in der forschung das
ist ja auch ein durchbruch denen dann
mal erwähnen muss die andere medikamente
sind nicht so schnell aber es hat nichts
anderes hat es bisher geschafft eine
ähnliche wirkung zu erzielen ja
nichtsdestotrotz wird das medikament ja
erstmal in ausgewählten kliniken nur
angewendet das hat auch den hintergrund
dass es wissenschaftlich begleitet wird
natürlich das ganz genau beobachtet wird
welche reaktionen gibt es es wird ja
auch jetzt immer noch dokumentiert um um
daten zu sammeln
das habe ich noch eine frage denn für
mich gibt's graf so ein klein
widerspruch sag ich mal ne auf der einen
seite sollen die patienten ja sehr früh
behandelt werden das
bundesgesundheitsministerium sagt
maximal drei tage nach einem positiven
pcr test aber in unikliniken zb da sind
eigentlich immer die fälle die dann
schon schwerer sind das heißt die
eigentlich schon einen etwas weiteren
kranken verlauf hat ist das ein problem
es ist sicherlich interessante frage was
hier die genauen vorstellungen sind
ich habe dir auch noch nicht erfahren
können ich kenne auch bisher nur die
pressemeldung aus dem ministerium
die genauen anweisungen an die
medizinischen fachkräfte muss man
natürlich noch einmal sehr genau dann
beobachten
aber was wir wissen aus den studien
amerika wo ja dieses medikament schon
über 4.200 kliniken momentan verfügbar
wird und er verfügbar ist und verwendet
wird ist dass man halt den besten effekt
erzielt wenn man so schnell wie es geht
nach der infektion dieses mittel gibt
und das ist auch nicht nur für einen
wissenschaftler einfach zu verstehen das
kann jeder verstehen denn wenn weniger
viren da sind weil sie sich nicht
vermehrt haben hat der antica von eine
bessere chance die alle sozusagen zu
packen alle aus dem verkehr zu ziehen
wenn das fünf tage später vielleicht
schon viele größenordnungen größere
virusmengen da sind da ist die gleiche
medikamenten menge die ist ja festgelegt
die dosis von der zulassung her in
amerika dann kann die dann auch schon
da wirken weil einfach viel zu viele
wären dann da sind insofern ist dieses
dieser empfehlung dass möglichst früh
anzuwenden
auch sinnvoll wir haben natürlich auch
noch bei den speziell bei diesen beiden
antikörpern noch eine möglichkeit dass
eine nebenwirkung entsteht durch eine
verstärkung in den späten phasen auch
das muss man sehr aufmerksam verfolgen
muss man untersuchen aber auch dafür
gibt es ideen wie man das verhindern
kann mit anderen präparaten auch zum
beispiel die haben eben schon
angesprochen die andere medikamente die
wir schon gesehen haben die eingesetzt
werden beziehungsweise wurden manche
haben sich gezeigt als nicht wirklich
sehr wirkungsvoll
wir wollen uns mal anschauen welche
medikamente das denn so sind und waren
zu beginn der pandemie setzten die
forscher innen große hoffnungen in
medikamente die ursprünglich zur
bekämpfung von krankheiten wie ebola
hepatitis c oder von anderen saß viren
entwickelt wurden in deutschland zb das
ebola medikamente die sie wir dass das
virus mit hilfe chemischer substanzen
bekämpfen sollte die whu spricht sich
inzwischen gegen den einsatz von rem die
sie wie raus es habe keinen einfluss auf
die sterblichkeit sogenannte
immunmodulatoren erwiesen sich dagegen
als wirksam
sie können die symptome einer kuh wird
19 erkrankungen mildern und werden
inzwischen als standard medikamente
verwendet
der einsatz von dexamethason einem
entzündungshemmer wird beispielsweise
auch von der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur befürwortet es
können die sterberate bei schweren
verläufen senken
die antikörper medikamente die nun auch
bald in deutschland zur verfügung stehen
sollen das virus selbst bekämpfen
mithilfe menschlicher proteine
wir haben also grund zur hoffnung mit
diesen neuen medikament das haben sie
uns ganz klar gemacht herr professor
dübel aber es gibt eine sag ich mal ein
problem nicht aber ein
möglicherweise unerwünschten nebeneffekt
als sogenannte überschießende
immunreaktion können sie uns das etwas
genauer erklären was das sein könnte im
fall der fälle den effekt den sie meinen
nennt man a.de oder antipathie dependent
in hansmann
das bedeutet dass in bestimmten fällen
ein antikörper eine virusinfektion auch
verstärken kann
da muss man jetzt nicht total alarmiert
seien deswegen sind antikörper nicht
schlecht sondern das ist etwas was man
molekular erforschen kann und was man
molekular zum beispiel bei den
vorherigen kroner virus fast van de -
und sei es auf 1 auch gesehen hat und
darauf könnte möglicherweise eine
nebenwirkung zurückzuführen sein
und diese überschießende immunreaktion
das ist alles hypothetisch wir wissen
noch sehr wenig über diesen virus in
seiner biologie wir tatsächlich im
menschen sich verhält dann das ist
natürlich sehr schwer da zu untersuchen
aber das ist eine vermutung dass das
dazu beitragen könnte dass zb die
medikamente von regeneron und lilly bei
schwer erkrankten patienten nicht mehr
so hilfreich sind und sie haben es ja
wohl bei ihrem medikament an dem sie
forschen auch in den griff bekommen das
ich sag mal mit laien würdigen
abzuschalten dass es diese
überschießende immunreaktion gibt also
im grunde sozusagen ein etwas besseres
präparat aber sie sind noch nicht so
weit dass dieses medikament tatsächlich
angewendet werden kann in denen in den
kliniken warum sind die amerikaner so
viel schneller
naja also zuerst einmal zu der ersten
äußerungen das ist unsere prothese mit
der wir jetzt in sehr kurzer zeit auch
in der klinik sein werden und das testen
werden
aber was wir wissen ist dass wir
zumindest diesen klassischen
wissenschaftliche mechanismus der hde
das enhancement und durch unser
medikament nicht auslösen können weil
wir haben einfach die entsprechenden
schalter in diesem molekül anders
eingestellt das kann man mit hilfe von
moderner
biologie machen wir haben also ein etwas
anderes konzept ob dieses konzept besser
ist muss sich tatsächlich in der klinik
jetzt erweisen wir hoffen da sehr bald
schon daten zu haben
aber man muss natürlich abwarten ob das
so funktioniert
wichtig ist es halt einfach solche
verschiedenen konzepte auch
auszuprobieren und nicht zu sagen wir
haben das problem jetzt gelöst weil wir
einen antikörper haben und kommt ja auch
noch die frage der mutation da kommen
wir sicher auch noch mal drauf auch da
brauchen wir mehrere als ein pfeil im
köcher und auf unser medikament jetzt
das ideale von allen ist das wissen wir
erst nach der klinischen studie und sind
die us hersteller schneller weil
vielleicht mehr gefördert wurde ich
glaube sie haben 500 millionen dollar
einsteckt in die entwicklung und das
passt ja auch zu einer anfrage die hier
kommt von patrick wie stark die politik
die medikamentenentwicklung und mit hand
fördert oder ob sich die politiker auf
impfstoffe fokussiert welchen eindruck
haben sie als jemand der selber vor und
vielleicht auch fördergelder auch
angewiesen ist ich muss die politik in
schutz nehmen die politik insgesamt hat
sehr viel getan für uns leider war es
nicht die bundespolitik die hat sich
nicht um die entwicklung gekümmert und
hat sie mehr oder weniger ignoriert und
hat sehr stark auf impfstoffe gesetzt
aber dann unsere landesregierung
niedersachsen die uns sehr stark
gefördert hat die uns die klinische
studie überhaupt ermöglicht hat jetzt
haben wir dieses medikament so weit
bringen können aber natürlich hatten wir
nicht 500 millionen förderung vom staat
am anfang bereits wie die amerikanischen
mitbewerber
dafür haben wir uns glaube ich ganz gut
geschlagen denn viel hinten dran sind
wir nicht und jetzt hat aber doch
bundesforschungsministerin carlitscheck
ich glaube am 6 januar war es ein
förderprogramm angekündigt von insgesamt
500 millionen euro da können sich jetzt
wissenschaftler bewerben mit ihren
projekten reicht das aus ihrer meinung
nach sind leider nur 50 millionen euro
und das ist weniger als man zum beispiel
für eine phase eine zulassungsstudie
braucht es kommt meiner meinung etwas zu
spät man hätte das vor einem jahr
gebraucht und gerade beginnen ist
außerdem erst im mai da hoffen wir dass
wir die ersten patienten schon geheilt
haben mit unserer medikament aber
natürlich ist es wichtig für die
förderung für neue forschungen für neue
medikamente auch weiter zu fördern
wir hätten uns gewünscht dass wir etwas
schneller gewesen wären mit etwas mehr
schub auch im sinne einer finanziellen
hilfe die noch schnellere entwicklung
erlaubt hätten dann die beschleunigung
kommt ja dadurch dass man dinge parallel
betreibt und schon dinge ausprobiert
bevor man auf das ergebnis der
vorherigen experimente wartet das hat
region sehr erfolgreich gemacht mit
hilfe dieser immens hohen antrags
finanzierung und da könnte man natürlich
noch verbessern in der zukunft ich hoffe
in der zukunft gibt es dafür strukturen
denn diese pandemie war nicht die letzte
ja und diese virus mutation diverse ist
auch nicht die letzte deswegen noch die
frage sie haben es eben schon gesagt
dass sie dieser frage schon weil
erwarten und axel anton fragt es auch ob
das medikament auch bei den virus
mutationen die wir kennen zum beispiel
aus großbritannien aus südafrika
funktioniert und auch das ist jetzt
meine frage noch obendrauf bei den
weiteren mutationen die ja noch zu
erwarten sind ja zum ersten ist eine
mutation natürlich etwas zufällig ist
das heißt man kann sich nicht darauf
vorbereiten sondern die natur überrascht
uns durch die vielfalt ihrer umgebung
strand hier strategien immer wieder
sie haben uns eine tolle hypothese
gemacht für einen wirkmechanismus und
denken sie dran beim aids virus hat es
eine kombination von drei medikamenten
und 15 jahre gedauert bis wir
tatsächlich die todeszahlen signifikant
herunter bekommen haben das wird hier so
wie der virus aussieht wie er sich
momentan verhält zum glück nicht so
lange dauern weil er sehr viel langsamer
mutiert und die mutation sind also
erwartbar dass es welche gibt aber
keiner kannte vorhersagen welche das
machen wo die gelegen haben und deswegen
ist es wichtig dass
eine vielzahl verschiedener werkstoffe
haben die von denen dann eine bestimmte
zahl noch bindet während einige dann
halt nicht mehr wirken und um auf ihre
konkrete frage noch zuschauer einzugehen
der chef von lilly hat zb einer
pressekonferenz kürzlich gesagt dass sie
also mit der einen mutanten
schwierigkeiten haben mit ihrem
medikament da wäre schon einer von zwei
pfeilen jetzt wieder stumpf geworden und
das zeigt warum wir weiterhin hier mit
volldampf an der entwicklung mindestens
fünf besser zehn neue antikörper
medikamente arbeiten sollen denn dann
wird auf jeden fall einer dabei sein der
auch eine zukünftige mutation mit ein
bisserl glück dann auch neutralisieren
kann also wir können uns noch nicht aufs
sofa legen wir müssen weiter arbeiten
sagte professor doktor stephan dübel die
botschaft ist angekommen bestimmt auch
bei der bundesregierung dankeschön dass
sie uns rede und antwort gestanden haben
geholfen haben dass etwas besser
einzuschätzen was diese medikamente
bedeuten wie sie wirken und was wir noch
tun müssen im kampf gegen kuwait 19
dankeschön nach braunschweig und
dankeschön liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer dass ihr dabei wahrt und eure
fragen gestellt habe wir wünschen noch
einen schönen abend